양자 정보와 계산 이해하기에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Watrous이고, IBM
Quantum의 교육 기술 디렉터예요. 이번이 시리즈의 10번째 강의이고, 세 번째 단원의 두 번째 강의인데요,
양자 정보의 일반적인 공식화에 관한 단원이에요. 이번 강의는 채널에 대한 내용인데,
채널은 양자 정보를 저장하는 시스템의 변화를 나타내요. 여기에는 다음과 같은 유용한 연산들이 포함되는데요,
unitary gate와 양자 circuit에 의해 수행되는 연산들, 그리고 노이즈처럼 우리가 피하고 싶은 변화들도 포함돼요. 측정도 설명할 수 있는데요,
채널로서의 측정은 다음 강의에서 다룰 거예요. 채널이라는 용어는
정보 이론에서 왔는데요, 정보 이론은 무엇보다도 잡음이 있는 통신
채널의 정보 전달 용량을 연구해요. 그래서 채널을 생각할 때, 우리는 통신
채널에 대해 추상적으로 생각하고 있는 거예요. 복잡한 계산을 통신 채널로 생각하는 게 좀 이상하게 느껴질 수도 있지만,
어떤 방식으로든 정보를 변환하는 과정이라는 일반적인 개념을 가리키는 단어가 필요해요. 좋든 싫든
채널이라는 단어가 굳어졌는데, 이는 정보 이론이, 특히
1940년대 Claude Shannon의 연구가 양자 정보와 계산에 미친 엄청난 영향 때문일 거예요. 이번 강의의
개요를 소개할게요. 기초부터 시작해서 채널이 무엇인지 정의하고, 단순화된 공식화에서의 unitary 연산이
어떻게 채널로 표현될 수 있는지도 다룰 거예요. 또한 채널의 볼록 결합이 채널이 된다는 것도 이야기할 텐데요,
왜 이 볼록성 개념이 계속 나오는지 궁금하시다면, 그건 이게 양자 정보 이론에서 정말로 근본적으로 중요한 수학적 개념이기 때문이에요.
또한 채널의 예시들도 살펴볼 텐데, 특히 qubit 채널을 볼 거예요. 이건 강의 나머지 부분에서도
계속 다시 나올 거예요. 강의의 두 번째 부분에서는 채널을 수학적으로 표현하는 세 가지 방법을 이야기할 거예요.
구체적으로 Stinespring 표현, Kraus 표현, 그리고 Choi
표현을 다룰 거예요. 이 이름들은 이 표현들의 발전에 중요한 기여를 한 세 사람의 이름을 딴 거예요. 세 번째이자
마지막 부분에서는 이 세 가지 표현이 실제로 동등하다는 것을 수학적으로 증명할 거예요. 또한 이것들이
채널의 정의를 모두 올바르게 특성화한다는 것도 다룰 거예요. 제 생각에는 정말 멋진 수학적 증명이고, 이 다양한
표현들이 어떻게 서로 관련되고 어떻게 작동하는지 명확하게 이해하는 데 도움이 될 거예요. 기초부터 시작해서
채널이란 무엇인가라는 질문을 다뤄 볼게요. 강의 시작 부분에서 말씀드렸듯이, 채널은 변화를 설명해요.
구체적으로는 양자 정보를 저장하는 시스템에서 이산 시간 변화를 나타내요. 여기서 이산 시간
변화라는 건 연속적인 과정과는 반대로, 두 개의 구별되는 시간 사이에 발생하는 변화를 생각하는 거예요.
예를 들어 무한소의 아주 작은 시간 간격에 걸쳐 생각하는 연속적인 과정과는 달라요. 채널에는
양자 gate와 circuit에 의해 수행되는 unitary 연산 같은 유용한 연산들, 그리고 노이즈로 인한 변화가 포함돼요.
하지만 이번 강의에서는 주로 채널을 추상적인 수학적 용어로 생각할 거예요. 유용한 것과 그렇지 않은 것을
굳이 구분할 필요는 없어요. 채널의 일반적인 이름으로는 그리스 대문자 파이,
사이, 델타 같은 것들을 써요. 특정 채널을 가리킬 때는 다른 문자를 쓸 거예요. 단순한 상황에서
어떤 밀도 행렬 ρ로 표현되는 상태에 있는 시스템이 있고, 그 시스템에 채널 Φ를 적용하면,
결과는 밀도 행렬 Φ(ρ)로 표현되는 상태의 시스템이에요. 즉, 주어진
채널 Φ를 특정 크기의 밀도 행렬에 적용할 수 있는 함수로 생각하는 거예요. 다시 말해서
이 채널을 적용하는 특정 시스템의 밀도 행렬에 적용하는 거예요. 채널이 유효한 채널로 간주되려면 몇 가지 요건을 충족해야 해요.
첫째, 채널은 선형 사상이에요. 이건 우리가 갖고 있는 상황과 완전히 유사한데요,
양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서 양자 상태 벡터에 대한 연산이 반드시 선형이어야 하는 것처럼요.
그리고 확률적 연산이 선형인 고전 정보의 표준 공식화에서도 마찬가지예요. 정말로 원한다면 이 선형성이라는
기본 요건에 의문을 제기할 수도 있어요. 하지만 확률 이론 모두와 일관된 이론을 원한다면,
그리고 양자 상태를 밀도 행렬로 표현하기로 선택했다면, 우리에게 선택의 여지가 없고 채널이 선형이라는 것을 그냥 받아들여야 해요.
두 번째 요건은 채널이 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환해야 한다는 거예요. 이건 완전히 타당한데요,
시스템의 상태를 밀도 행렬로 표현하기로 선택하고, 어떤 상태에 있는 시스템에 채널을 적용하면, 결과도 유효한 상태여야 하고 따라서
밀도 행렬로 표현돼야 해요. 하지만 여기서 매우 중요한 점을 추가해야 해요. 이 요건은
채널을 밀도 행렬로 상태가 표현되는 고립된 시스템에 적용할 때만 적용되는 게 아니에요.
복합 시스템이 있고 그 상태가 어떤 밀도 행렬로 표현될 때, 그 시스템의 일부에만
채널을 적용하는 경우에도 적용돼요. 이것이 채널에 두는 요건들이고, 이것들이
양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화와 고전 정보의 표준 공식화 모두에서 연산에 대한 요건들과 매우 유사하다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서 연산은 unitary 행렬로 표현되는데, 이건 그것들이
주어진 시스템에 대해 항상 양자 상태 벡터를 양자 상태 벡터로 변환하는 선형 사상에 정확히 대응하기 때문이에요.
마찬가지로 확률적 연산은 확률 행렬로 표현되는데, 이것들이
항상 확률 벡터를 확률 벡터로 변환하는 것들이기 때문이에요. 여기서는 밀도 행렬을 다루고 있고,
복합 시스템에 관한 추가 요건이 있어요. 이건 양자 상태 벡터에는 필요하지 않은 것으로 밝혀졌는데,
확률 벡터도 마찬가지예요. 그 외에는 요건들이 유사하고, 어떤 의미에서는 양자 상태를 밀도 행렬로
표현하는 선택에 의해 강요된 것들이에요. 채널에 대한 추가 세부사항들이 있는데, 강의 전반에 걸쳐
채널의 입력 및 출력 시스템을 어떻게 생각할지에 대한 관례와, 채널이 항상 밀도 행렬을
밀도 행렬로 변환해야 한다는 요건에 대한 더 자세한 내용도 있어요. 우선 모든 채널에는
입력 시스템과 출력 시스템이 있다고 가정해요. 원하는 대로 이름을 붙일 수 있지만,
이번 강의에서는 입력 시스템을 X, 출력 시스템을 Y라고 부를 거예요. 개념적으로 채널은
입력 시스템을 출력 시스템으로 변환해요. 그래서 입력과 출력 시스템은 동시에 공존하지 않아요.
X에서 시작해서 채널이 적용 또는 수행되고, 그 결과는 X가 Y로 변환된 것이에요. Y의 상태는
채널과 관련된 선형 사상에 의해 결정돼요. 채널의 입력과 출력 시스템이 같을 필요는 없고, 특히
같은 수의 고전적 상태를 가질 필요도 없어요. 하지만 입력과 출력 시스템이 실제로 같은 시스템이거나 다른 방식으로
즉 X=Y인 경우인데, 이 경우에는 단순히 Φ가 시스템의 상태를 변환하고 있다고 상상하는 거예요. 실제로 이게
우리가 관심 있는 경우가 매우 많아요. 하지만 이 가능성은 첫 번째 요점과 일치해요. 즉 입력과 출력 시스템이 동시에 두 개의 별도 시스템으로 존재하지 않는다는 의미에서요.
어쨌든 이번 강의에서는 입력과 출력 시스템을 각각 X와 Y라는 다른 문자로 부르는 게
편리할 거예요. 이렇게 하면 헷갈리지 않고 정리할 수 있거든요. 이제 채널이 항상 밀도
행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환해야 한다는 요건에 대해 좀 더 자세히 알아볼게요. 새로운 시스템 Z를 도입한다고 해봐요.
이 새로운 시스템의 고전적 상태 집합에 gamma라는 이름을 붙여봐요. 이제 채널 Φ의 입력 시스템 X와
함께 새로운 복합 시스템 ZX를 형성한다고 상상해 봐요. 이 복합 시스템이
밀도 행렬 ρ로 표현되는 상태에 있다고 가정해요. 이건 이 쌍의 임의의 양자 상태일 수 있는데, 어떤 상태든
밀도 행렬 ρ를 화면에 표시된 형식으로 표현하는 것이 항상 가능해요. 여기서 A와 B 모두
고전적 상태 집합 gamma를 범위로 하고, 각 ρ_AB는 행과 열이 X의 고전적 상태 집합에 대응하는 행렬이에요.
그 고전적 상태 집합에 이름을 붙일 필요는 없어요. 명확히 말하면, 각 ρ_AB가 반드시 그 자체로
밀도 행렬인 건 아니지만, 전체 행렬 ρ는 반드시 밀도 행렬이에요. 시스템 X에 채널 Φ를 적용하면
X가 Y로 변환되고, 쌍 ZY가 남아요. Φ를 X에만 수행한 후 이 쌍의 상태를 결정하는 방법은
각 행렬 ρ_AB에 선형 사상 Φ를 적용하는 거예요.
다르게 말하면, gamma에 대응하는 행과 열을 갖는 정방 행렬에 대한 항등 사상과 Φ의 텐서곱을 취하는 거예요.
이는 새로운 시스템 Z에는 아무것도 하지 않는 것에 해당해요. 하지만 이건 동등한
설명이고, 이 형태의 사상의 텐서곱에 대한 세부사항을 꼭 다룰 필요는 없어요.
하지만 텐서곱은 벡터와 행렬에서 작동하는 방식과 유사하게 꽤 직관적으로 작동해요. 이걸 시각적으로 생각하는 한 가지 방법은
블록 행렬의 관점에서 보는 거예요. 고전적 상태 집합 gamma가 어떤 양의 정수 M에 대해
0부터 N-1까지의 정수로 구성된다는 단순화 가정을 하면, 이것을 모두 쉽게 적을 수 있어요.
여기 보이는 것처럼요. 이제 Φ가 유효한 채널이 되기 위한 요건을 다시 한번 말씀드리면, 이 과정에서 항상 밀도
행렬을 얻어야 해요. 이건 시스템 Z의 선택과 관계없이, 그리고
밀도 행렬이기만 하면 ρ의 선택과도 관계없이 성립해야 해요. 이게 꽤 엄격한 요건처럼 보일 수도 있고,
확인하기도 매우 어려워 보일 수 있어요. 하지만 강의 끝에서 보게 되겠지만 사실 그렇게 엄격하지도
않고 확인하기 어렵지도 않아요. 특히 이 조건에 대한 좋은 수학적 특성화가 있어요.
이것들은 강의에서 조금 후에 이야기할 다양한 표현들과 연결되어 있어요. 이제 채널의 예시들을 살펴볼게요.
unitary 채널이라고 불리는 전체 채널 범주부터 시작할게요. 간단히 말하면, 이것들은
양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서 갖고 있는 것처럼 채널로 본 unitary 연산이에요. 정확히 말하면, U가
시스템 X에 대한 unitary 연산을 나타내는 unitary 행렬이라고 가정해요. 양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서는
이 행렬을 주어진 양자 상태 벡터에 곱해서 그 연산이 양자 상태에 미치는 효과를 알아내요.
밀도 행렬에서는 밀도 행렬 왼쪽에 U를, 오른쪽에 U
dagger를 곱해요. 수학적으로는 이 연산을 행렬 U에 의한 켤레로 불러요. 이건
|ψ⟩⟨ψ|가 양자 상태 벡터 ψ로 표현되는 상태를 나타내는 밀도 행렬이라는 것과 일치해요.
그리고 특히 양자 상태 벡터 |ψ⟩에 U를 수행하면 U|ψ⟩를 얻는다는 걸 확인하기 꽤 쉬워요.
그리고 그 밀도 행렬 표현은 그 벡터와 켤레 전치의 곱으로 주어지는데, 이는 U|ψ⟩⟨ψ|U
dagger예요. U|ψ⟩의 켤레 전치를 계산했을 때요. 이 채널이 정의되는 방식은
순수 상태에 대해 의미가 있고, 이것과 선형성을 결합하면 일반 밀도 행렬에 대해서도 의미가 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
모든 밀도 행렬이 순수 상태의 볼록 결합으로 표현될 수 있기 때문이에요.
이 정의는 임의의 unitary 연산 U에 대해 항상 유효한 채널을 제공해요. 특히 이런 식으로 unitary 행렬로
켤레를 취하면 행렬의 대각합이 변하지 않아요. 임의의 양의 반정치
행렬을 임의의 행렬로 켤레 취하면 또 다른 양의 반정치 행렬을 얻게 되고,
이건 양의 반정치 행렬의 정의로부터 직접 꽤 쉽게 구할 수 있어요. 그래서 밀도 행렬은 항상 밀도
행렬로 사상돼요. 그리고 이 모든 것은 임의 크기의 항등 행렬과 U를 텐서곱해도 여전히 성립해요.
이는 이 채널을 복합 시스템의 일부에만 적용하는 것과 동등해요. 여기 unitary 채널의 정말 간단한 예시가 있어요.
U 자체를 항등 행렬로 취한다고 가정해요. 이건 항등 채널이라고 불리는 유효한 채널이에요.
아무것도 하지 않는 게 확실히 선형 연산이고, 밀도 행렬에서 시작해서 아무것도 하지 않으면
여전히 밀도 행렬이니까요. 이 채널을 나타내는 기호로 다양한 것들을 써요.
때로는 항등 행렬에 사용하는 것과 완전히 같은 기호를 쓰는데, 이게 약간 혼란스러울 수 있지만 보통은 그렇지 않아요. 여기서는
혼란을 피하기 위해 항등의 약자인 ID 문자를 쓸 거예요. 이 표기법도 꽤 일반적이에요. 매우
지루한 채널처럼 보일 수 있지만, 정보 전송의 맥락에서는 실제로 완벽한 채널이에요.
수신자가 발신자가 보낸 것을 정확히 받는 채널인데, 이런 맥락에서는 일반적으로 가장 원하는 거예요.
채널의 많은 예시를 얻을 수 있는 또 다른 방법은 채널의 볼록 결합을 취하거나, 다시 말해 평균을 내는 거예요.
이것이 가능하다는 사실은 채널의 중요한 측면이에요. 이걸 더 자세히 설명하기 위해 두 채널 Φ_0와 Φ_1부터 시작해요.
그리고 0과 1 사이의 실수 p도 함께 고려해요. 명확히 말하면, 이 두 채널이
같은 입력 시스템 X와 같은 출력 시스템 Y를 갖는다고 가정하는 거예요. 이제 확률 p로 첫 번째 채널 Φ_0를
적용하고, 나머지 확률 1-p로 두 번째 채널 Φ_1을 적용하기로 결정하면 어떻게 되는지 생각해 봐요.
예를 들어, 그 확률로 비트를 무작위로 선택한 다음 이 무작위
비트를 사용해 어느 채널을 적용할지 결정하는 거예요. 이렇게 하면 사이라고 부를 수 있는 새로운 채널을 효과적으로 적용하는 거예요.
이건 시작했던 두 채널의 볼록 결합으로 주어지는데,
화면에 쓰여진 것처럼 표현할 수 있어요. 이런 식으로 선형 사상의 선형 결합을 항상 취할 수 있어요.
그리고 이런 식의 선형
사상의 선형 결합이 주어진 입력에서 어떻게 정의되는지는, 출력의 같은 선형 결합을 취하면 돼요.
이건 좀 사소해 보일 수 있지만 말이 돼요. 이 가상의 시나리오에서 얻는 출력은 단순히
두 원래 채널에서 얻을 출력의 가중 평균이에요. 그럼에도 이건 새로운 채널이고,
Φ_0와 Φ_1이 유효한 채널이었다면, 이 새로운 사상도 확실히 유효한 채널이 될 거예요. 이걸 수학적으로
다르게 말하면, 주어진 입력 시스템에서 주어진 출력 시스템으로의 모든 채널의 집합은
볼록이라는 거예요. 이건 채널의 중요한 수학적 특성이에요. M개의 채널 Φ_0부터 Φ_이 있으면 더 일반적으로 할 수 있어요.
각 채널에 대한 확률을 알려주는 확률 벡터와 함께라면, 채널들을 그에 따라 평균해서 새로운 채널을 얻을 수 있어요.
어떤 의미에서 이건 새로운 채널의 무한한 원천이에요. 예를 들어, 소위 혼합 unitary 채널이라는 것은
unitary 채널의 볼록 결합을 취해서 얻는 거예요. 즉, 같은 크기의 M개의 unitary 행렬 U_0부터 U_이 있고
확률 벡터와 함께라면, 개별 unitary 행렬들에 대응하는 채널들의 가중 평균을 취하면,
화면에서 보이는 것처럼, 채널을 얻을 수 있어요. 그리고 이렇게 쓸 수 있는 채널들을
혼합 unitary 채널이라고 불러요. 모든 채널이 혼합 unitary 채널인 건 아니에요.
이 방법으로 모든 채널을 얻을 수는 없지만, 꽤 자주 등장해요. 다음으로 채널의 몇 가지 구체적인
예시를 살펴볼게요. 이것들은 모두 하나의 qubit에서 하나의 qubit로의 채널 예시인데, 줄여서 qubit
채널이라고 불러요. 첫 번째는 qubit 리셋 채널이라고 불리고, 이 채널은 qubit을
영 상태로 리셋해요. 여기서 그리스 대문자 Lambda를 이 채널을 나타내는 데 써요. 이 채널이 무엇을 하는지 기억하는 방법은
블로흐 구를 생각해 보는 거예요. 대문자 Lambda는 위를 가리키는 화살표처럼 보이고, 영 상태는 블로흐 구의 꼭대기에 있어요. 마치
출력의 위치를 가리키는 것 같아요. 수학적으로는 Lambda(ρ) = Tr(ρ)|0⟩⟨0|로 정의돼요.
임의의 밀도 행렬 ρ에 적용하면 밀도 행렬로서의 영 상태를 얻어요. 왜 대각합이 필요한지 궁금해지는 건 자연스러워요.
Lambda(ρ)를 앞에 Tr(ρ) 없이 그냥 |0⟩⟨0|로 정의할 수는 없는 건가요?
그 질문의 답은 '아니오'예요. 채널은 선형 사상이어야 하는데, Tr(ρ)를 제거하면 선형이 되지 않아요. 또한 때로는
밀도 행렬이 아닌 입력에 대한 선형 사상으로서 채널이 어떻게 작동하는지 알아야 한다는 것도 기억하세요.
예를 들어, 앞서 봤듯이 복합 시스템에 채널을 적용할 때 어떻게 되는지 알려면,
더 큰 블록 행렬의 개별 블록들에 그 채널을 적용해야 해요. 전체 블록 행렬이
밀도 행렬일 수 있더라도, 개별 블록들은 일반적으로 밀도 행렬이 아니에요. 이 채널을 복합 시스템의 한 부분에만
적용하면 정확히 어떻게 되는지, 더 구체적으로는 ebit을 형성하는 두 qubit 중 하나에 적용하면
어떻게 되는지 살펴볼게요. 정확히 말하면, A와 B가 쌍으로 Φ+ Bell 상태에 있는 qubit들이고, Lambda를
첫 번째 qubit A에 적용한다고 가정해요. 어떻게 되는지 알아보기 위해, 먼저 Φ+ 상태를 밀도 행렬로 표현하고,
이 예시를 위해 직접 표기법을 써서 해볼게요. 여기 양자 상태 벡터로서의 Φ+ 상태가 있고, 이 벡터와 켤레 전치를 곱하고
모두 전개하면 이렇게 돼요. 그러면 첫 번째 qubit에 채널을 적용하고 결과를 계산할 수 있어요.
첫 번째 qubit에 Lambda를 적용한 결과예요. 각 항을 계산하면, Tr(|0⟩⟨0|)=1이고
Tr(|1⟩⟨1|)=1이에요. 그래서 이 두 경우에 채널의 출력은 |0⟩⟨0|이고, 이게 답의
두 항을 설명해요. 반면 Tr(|0⟩⟨1|)=0이고 Tr(|1⟩⟨0|)=0이에요.
그래서 그 두 항은 0으로 계산되고, 따라서 답에 아무런 기여도 하지 않아요.
이제 조금 단순화하면, 첫 번째 qubit A에 대한 영 상태와
두 번째 qubit B에 대한 완전 혼합 상태를 얻어요. 특히 B에 대해 + 상태를 얻지 않는다는 점에 주목하세요.
밀도 행렬에 대해 아무것도 모르고 상태의 양자 상태 벡터 표현만 봤다면, 그게 그럴듯한 추측이었을 수 있어요. 하지만 그건
이 채널의 작동 방식이 아니고, 이렇게 작동할 수 있는 채널은 없어요. 채널 Lambda는 qubit 리셋 채널이라고 불리지만,
실제 작동 방식은 입력 qubit을 버리고 영 상태의 새로운 qubit으로 교체하는 것에 가까워요. 실제로 이건
항상 영 상태를 출력하는 유일한 qubit 채널이에요. 여기 qubit 채널의 또 다른 예시가 있는데,
완전 위상 제거 채널이라고 알려진 거예요. 이건 Delta로 표시되고, 작동 방식은 임의의 2x2 행렬의 대각
항목들을 그대로 두고 비대각 항목들을 0으로 만드는 거예요. Delta는 라틴 알파벳의 D에 해당하는 그리스 문자이고,
이는 대각(diagonal)의 약자예요. 그래서 이 채널이 무엇을 하는지 기억하는 한 가지 방법이에요.
화면에서 보이는 것처럼 직접 표기법을 사용해서 이 채널을 대안적으로 표현할 수도 있어요. 명확히 말하면, 출력은
항상 2x2 행렬이에요. 그래서 특히 두 개의 영 출력은 전부 영인 2x2 행렬을 가리켜요. 이런 걸
자주 하는데, 이 시리즈에서 전에도 봤어요. 기호 0은 일반적으로 어떤 것을 다루든, 스칼라든 벡터든 행렬이든, 그 것의 영 원소를
의미하는 데 약간 모호하게 쓰여요. qubit 리셋 채널에서 했던 것과 같은 걸 해봐요.
이 채널을 ebit의 절반에 적용하면 어떻게 되는지 봐요. 설정은 같으니 그 부분은 넘어갈게요.
결과는 화면에 표시된 상태인데, 이건 본질적으로 공유 랜덤 비트예요. 이 채널이 한 건
기본적으로 ebit을 완벽하게 상관된 고전적 랜덤 비트 쌍으로 변환한 거예요.
이는 이 채널의 더 일반적인 해석과 일치해요. 밀도 행렬의 비대각 항목들을 0으로 만듦으로써, 효과적으로
밀도 행렬에서 양자적인 부분을 버리고, 고전적 확률 상태를 나타내는 대각 밀도 행렬을 남겨요.
이걸 생각하는 또 다른 방법은 이 채널이 비트를 전송하는 완벽한 잡음 없는 고전적 채널을 나타낸다는 거예요.
영 상태나 일 상태 또는 그 두 상태의 볼록 결합을 채널에 넣으면, 그 상태가 변하지 않고 나와요. 하지만 + 상태 같은
양자 상태를 넣으려고 하면, 마치 채널이 표준 기저 측정으로 그 상태를 측정하고
고전적 결과를 전송하는 것처럼 돼요. qubit 채널의 마지막 예시는 완전 편극 제거 채널이에요.
이 채널이 하는 건 항상 완전 혼합 상태를 출력하는 거예요. 어떤 의미에서 qubit 리셋 채널과 비슷하지만,
초기화된 qubit 대신 그다지 유용하지 않은 완전 혼합 상태가 나와요. 이 채널을 생각하는 자연스러운 방법은
극단적인 형태의 노이즈를 나타낸다는 거예요. qubit 채널에 관한 한, 이것보다 더 잡음이 많을 수는 없어요.
이게 무엇을 하는지 기억하기 위한 좋은 기억법은 없는데, Omega가 그리스 알파벳의 마지막
문자이고 때로 모든 것의 끝과 연결된다는 것 외에는요. 어쩌면 이게 여기서 일어나는 일일 수도 있어요.
결국 모든 qubit에 해당되는 거예요. 노이즈 측면에서는 꽤 극단적이지만, 한 가지 할 수 있는 건 이 채널과 항등 채널의 볼록 결합을 고려하는 거예요.
완전 편극 제거에 아마도 작은 확률 엡실론으로요.
이건 덜 극단적인 형태의 노이즈인데, 주어진 qubit 상태가 대부분 그대로 있지만
완전히 혼합될 작은 가능성이 있어요. 기하학적으로는 블로흐 구가 중심 쪽으로 약간 수축하는 것으로 생각할 수 있어요.
그리고 비슷한 걸 완전 위상 제거 채널로도 할 수 있는데, 예를 들어 디코히어런스 과정을 모델링하기 위해서요.
어떤 과정을 통해 약간 더 고전적이 되는 것처럼요. 이것들이 qubit 채널의 세 가지 기본 예시이고,
강의의 나머지 부분에서 주로 예시의 원천으로 다시 다룰 거예요. 다음으로 채널의 수학적
표현에 대해 논의할 건데, 기본적인 질문부터 시작해요. 벡터에서 벡터로의 선형 사상은 항상
익숙한 방식으로 행렬로 표현될 수 있어요. 선형 사상의 작용이 행렬
벡터 곱셈으로 표현되는 방식으로요. 하지만 채널은 행렬에서 행렬로의 선형 사상이지, 벡터에서 벡터로가 아니에요.
그래서 일반적으로 채널을 수학적으로 어떻게 표현할 수 있을까요? 특별한 채널에 대해서는 때로
간단한 공식이 있는데, 앞서 논의한 qubit 채널 예시들이 그런 경우였어요. 하지만 그건
일반적으로 실용적이지 않아요. 그런 좋은 공식이 항상 있는 건 아니거든요. 비교 대상으로, 양자 정보의 단순화된
공식화에서는 양자 상태 벡터에 대한 연산을 나타내기 위해 unitary 행렬을 사용해요.
모든 unitary 행렬이 유효한 연산을 나타내고, 모든 유효한 연산이 unitary 행렬로 표현될 수 있어요. 본질적으로
이 질문이 묻는 건 채널에 대해서는 어떻게 하냐는 거예요. 이 질문의 답은 채널을 수학적으로 표현하는 방법이
실제로 여러 가지 있다는 거예요. 특히 채널을 표현하는 세 가지 다른 방법을 논의할 건데,
그 개발에 중요한 역할을 한 세 사람의 이름을 딴 것들이에요. Stinespring, Kraus, 그리고 Choi예요.
먼저 이 다양한 표현들이 어떻게 작동하는지 살펴보고, 강의의 마지막 부분에서 세 표현이 어떻게 관련되는지,
특히 어떻게 변환할 수 있는지 살펴볼 거예요. 또한 이 표현들이 채널에 대한 요건들을 정확히 포착한다는 것도 알게 될 거예요.
즉, 선형 사상이어야 하고, 복합 시스템의 일부에만 적용될 때도
항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환해야 한다는 거예요. 첫 번째로 Stinespring 표현을 다룰 거예요. William Forrest Stinespring은
양자 정보 연구를 하지 않은 수학자였고, 제가 설명할 Stinespring 표현은
어떤 의미에서 1950년대 연산자 이론에 관한 그의 연구의 파생물에 불과해요. 하지만 이 연구는 분명히
양자 채널의 기반이 되는 수학 발전의 중요한 부분이었어요. 채널을 표현하는 이 방법의 아이디어는 모든
채널이 제가 이제 설명할 특정 방법으로 구현될 수 있다는 거예요. 먼저 구현하려는 채널의
입력과 초기화된 작업 공간 시스템으로 구성된 복합 시스템을 형성해요. 그런 다음
복합 시스템에 unitary 연산을 수행하고, 마지막으로 결과 복합 시스템에서
채널의 출력에 해당하는 부분은 그대로 두거나 출력하고 나머지는 버리거나 trace out해요. 이걸
다이어그램 형태로 표현하면 이해하기 쉬운데, 입력과 출력 시스템이 같은 특수한 경우부터 시작하는 게 가장 간단해요.
이 다이어그램은 quantum circuit 다이어그램과 같은데, 선들이 임의의 시스템을 나타내고 반드시 단일 qubit일 필요는 없어요.
그래서 입력 시스템 X가 어떤 상태 ρ에 있는 것부터 시작해요. 초기화된 작업 공간 시스템 W를 도입하고,
이 다이어그램에서는 0이 W의 고전적 상태이고 시스템의 초기화된 상태로 |0⟩을 취하고 있지만,
W의 임의의 순수 상태를 대신 고정해서 초기화된 상태로 볼 수도 있어요. 그런 다음 쌍 WX에 unitary 연산을 수행하고
작업 공간 시스템을 trace out하고 X를 출력해요. 다이어그램에서 W가 버려진다는 걸 나타내기 위해
전기 공학의 접지 기호를 쓰고 있어요. 이게 반드시 관례적인 건 아니고, Qiskit에서는 찾을 수 없을 거예요.
Qiskit에서는 관심 없는 qubit들을 그냥 무시해요. 중요한 건 이 논의를 위해 시스템이 버려진다는 걸
명확히 하는 기호가 필요하다는 거예요. 일반적으로 입력과 출력 시스템이 같을 필요는 없어서,
예를 들어 출력 시스템 Y와 함께
trace out되는 쓰레기 시스템 G가 있을 수 있어요. U가 unitary이려면 정방 행렬이어야 하므로,
쌍 GY가 쌍 WX와 같은 수의 고전적 상태를 갖는다는 가정이 있어요. 예를 들어 이 시스템들이
qubit들로 구성되고, 입력 시스템 X가 5개의 qubit, W가 10개의 qubit로 구성된다면, U는 15 qubit에 대한 unitary
연산이에요. 그러면 Y가 4개의 qubit로만 구성될 수 있고, G는 11개의 qubit로 구성돼요.
아니면 이게 qubit이 전혀 아닐 수도 있어요. 중요한 건 WX와 GY가 함께 같은 수의 고전적 상태를 가져야
U가 unitary일 수 있다는 거예요. 이런 식의 채널 설명을 채널의 Stinespring 표현이라고 해요. 이제
이런 식으로 설명될 수 있는 임의의 사상 Φ가 실제로 유효한 채널임을 주장하기 꽤 쉬워요.
특히 밀도 행렬에서 시작해서 추가적인 작업 공간 시스템을 덧붙이면, 분명히
밀도 행렬이 남아요. unitary 연산을 적용하면 유효한 채널을 준다는 건 이미 알았고,
복합 시스템의 밀도 행렬에서 시스템 중 하나를 trace out하면, 다시 밀도 행렬이 남아요. 이 단계들을
합성하면 항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환함이 보장되고, 또한 선형이에요.
이 시점에서 전혀 명확하지 않은 건, 모든 채널이 실제로 작업 공간 시스템과 쓰레기 시스템,
그리고 물론 unitary 연산 U에 대한 어떤 선택으로 이런 방식으로 구현될 수 있다는 거예요. 하지만 그건 사실이고,
강의 끝에서 왜 그런지 알게 될 거예요. 여기 완전 위상 제거 qubit 채널에 대한 Stinespring 표현 예시가 있어요.
명확히 말하면, 이제 선들은 qubit이고, 이건 일반적인 controlled-NOT gate예요.
매우 간단해요. 입력 qubit은 위에 있고, 영 상태로 초기화된 작업 공간 qubit을 도입해요.
그런 다음 입력 qubit이 제어이고 작업 공간 qubit이 타겟인 controlled-NOT 연산을 수행하고,
작업 공간 qubit을 trace out해요. 직관적으로, 이게 완전 위상 제거 채널을 구현해야 한다는 게 말이 돼요.
controlled-NOT gate가 위의 qubit에 표준 기저 측정처럼 작동해서 고전적 상태를 아래 qubit에 복사하고,
그런 다음 결과가 버려지기 때문이에요.
하지만 계산을 직접 해볼 수도 있고, 물론 그렇게 하는 게 좋아요. 왜냐하면 정말로
버려지기 때문이에요. 하지만 계산을 직접 해볼 수도 있고, 물론 그렇게 하는 게 좋아요. 왜냐하면 정말로
직관을 너무 믿으면 안 되거든요. 작업 공간 qubit이 도입된 후 두 qubit의 밀도 행렬 표현을 적는 것부터 시작할 수 있어요.
그리고 qubit 순서 규칙을 평소처럼 사용한다는 점에 주목하세요.
아래 qubit이 왼쪽이고 위 qubit이 오른쪽이에요. 이 밀도 행렬을
화면에 표시된 것처럼 실제 4x4 행렬로 명시적으로 표현할 수 있고, 그런 다음 controlled-NOT gate가
이 밀도 행렬에 미치는 효과를 계산해요. 그래서 이 gate와 관련된 unitary 행렬로 켤레를 취하고,
qubit 순서 규칙을 다시 한번 염두에 두어요. 그래서 이게 올바른 unitary
행렬이고, 결과가 여기 표시돼요. 효과적으로 controlled-NOT gate가
원래 행렬의 항목들을 약간 섞었고, 이제 0이 아닐 수 있는 항목들이
네 모서리에 있어요. 부분 대각합을 계산하는 것이 남았는데, 행렬에서 직접 할 수도 있지만,
대안으로 화면에 표시된 것처럼 직접 표기법으로 변환하면 각 항에서
왼쪽의 qubit을 trace out할 때 무슨 일이 일어나는지 계산하기 꽤 쉬워져요. 결과적으로
ρ의 대각 항목에 해당하는 항들만 남고, 예상대로 qubit의 위상을 제거했어요.
언제나 그렇듯이, 원하신다면 직접 여유 있게 확인해 보세요. 좋은
연습 예제로, 밀도 행렬과 부분 대각합으로 작업하는 실력을 쌓을 수 있어요.
이게 완전 위상 제거 채널을 구현하는 유일한 방법은 아니에요. 이 채널에 대한 대안적인 Stinespring 표현이 있어요.
이 영상에서 계산을 자세히 다루지는 않겠지만, 잠깐 보여드릴 거예요. 영상을 잠시 멈추고 자세히 보고 싶다면요.
작동 방식은 첫 번째와 비슷하지만 세부 사항이
달라요. 이번에는 작업 공간 qubit에 Hadamard gate로 시작해서 + 상태로 만들어요. 그리고
텐서곱을 전개하면 화면에 표시된 행렬을 얻어요. controlled-Z gate를 적용하기 위해
관련 unitary 행렬로 켤레를 취하면, 결과적으로 행렬에 일부 마이너스 부호가 삽입돼요.
특히 마지막 행과 마지막 열이 모두 -1을 곱해져요.
이번에는 직접 표기법으로 변환하면 좀 지저분하니까, 직접
부분 대각합을 계산할 거예요. 두 qubit 중 첫 번째를 trace out하면 두 대각 2x2 블록의 합이 나와요.
그래서 최종 결과는 다시 qubit의 위상이 제거된 거예요. 빠르네요. 이런 계산에 익숙하지 않다면,
천천히 여유 있게 해보세요. 속도는 중요하지 않아요.
이 예시를 마무리하기 위해, 이 구현 뒤에 꽤 간단한 아이디어가 있다는 걸 말씀드릴게요.
이건 방금 훑어본 계산의 마지막 단계에서 꽤 잘 표현돼요. 더 간결하게 말하면,
주어진 qubit 밀도 행렬과 Pauli Z 행렬로 켤레 취한 밀도 행렬을 평균하면
위상 제거와 같다는 거예요. 즉 완전 위상 제거 채널은 혼합 unitary
채널인데, 각각 1/2의 확률로 아무것도 안 하거나, 즉 항등 연산을 수행하거나, Z gate를 수행해요.
알아두면 좋아요. 요약하면, 완전 위상 제거 채널의 두 가지 다른 Stinespring 표현이 있고,
이건 중요한 것을 알려줘요. Stinespring 표현은 유일하지 않고, 실제로 주어진 채널에 대해 무한히 많이 있어요.
다음으로 Kraus 표현을 논의할 거예요. 행렬 곱셈과 덧셈을 통해 채널을 표현하는 편리한 공식적 방법을 제공해요.
Kraus 표현은 Karl Kraus의 이름을 딴 것인데, 그는 무엇보다도
채널의 기본 수학적 세부 사항을 많이 정리하고 더 넓게는 양자 정보의 일반 공식화를 연구한 물리학자예요.
일반적으로 Kraus 표현은 화면에 표시된 형태를 취하는 채널의 표현이에요. 특히
어떤 양의 정수 n에 대해 A_0부터 A_이라고 불리는 행렬들의 모음이 있고, 이것들이
공식에 따라 임의의 주어진 입력 ρ에 대한 채널의 작용을 지정해요. 간단히 말해, ρ를 이 행렬들 각각으로 켤레를 취하고,
이 맥락에서 종종 Kraus 행렬이라고 불리는 이 행렬들로 켤레를 취한 다음, 결과를 합산해서 출력을 얻어요.
이 모든 행렬들은 같은 차원을 가져야 하고, 구체적으로 열이 입력 시스템의 고전적 상태에 대응하고
행이 출력 시스템의 고전적 상태에 대응해야 해요. 그렇다면 임의의 K에 대해 A_K * ρ * A_K†의 곱을 취하면
행과 열이 출력 시스템의 고전적 상태에 대응하는 정방 행렬을 얻고,
그래서 이 식이 출력 시스템의 밀도 행렬을 생성한다는 게 말이 돼요. 이제 이 Kraus 행렬들을
임의로 선택한다고 유효한 채널을 얻는 건 아니에요. 하지만 유효한 채널을 얻음을 보장하는 행렬들에 대한
꽤 간단한 조건이 있어요. 그 조건은 바로 여기 표시된 공식이에요.
구체적으로, K의 모든 값에 대해 A_K† * A_K의 곱의 합이
항등 행렬이 되어야 해요. 그리고 그 항등 행렬은 행과 열이
입력 시스템의 고전적 상태에 대응하는 것이에요. 그 조건이 만족되어야 첫 번째 방정식으로 정의된 사상이
유효한 채널이 돼요. 그리고 모든 채널은 n을 충분히 크게 취하는 한
실제로 이 형태를 취하는 표현을 갖는 것으로 밝혀졌어요. 여기 Kraus 표현의 몇 가지 예시가 있어요.
qubit 리셋 채널부터 시작해서, |0⟩⟨0|와 |0⟩⟨1|이라는 두 개의 Kraus 행렬을 사용해서
이 채널의 Kraus 표현을 얻을 수 있어요. 이 예시에서 n은 2와 같아요.
이 선택들을 일반 공식에 대입하면 두 항만 있어서, 합을 쉽게 적을 수 있어요.
단순화하고 괄호 안의 식이 ρ의 대각합임을 인식하면, qubit 리셋 채널을 얻는다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
또한 이 행렬들에 대한 필요한 조건이 충족되는지 확인할 수 있는데, Kraus 행렬들을
방정식에 대입하고 계산하는 단순한 문제이고, 필요한 대로 항등 행렬을 얻어요. 또 다른 예시로 완전 위상 제거 채널을
다시 살펴봐요. |0⟩⟨0|와 |1⟩⟨1| 행렬을 취하면 작동하고, 합을 전개해서
필요한 것을 꽤 직접적으로 얻는지 확인할 수 있어요. 다시 한번 필요한 조건이 충족돼요.
대안은 A_0를 I/√2로, A_1을
σ_Z/√2로 취하는 거예요. 계산하면 다시 완전 위상 제거 채널을 얻는다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
앞서 관찰한 것에 기반해서요.
강의 좀 앞부분에서 이 채널에 대해 관찰한 것에 기반해서요. 그리고 다시 한번 필요한 조건은 확인하기 꽤 간단해요.
도움이 된다면 연습 문제로 풀어보세요. 완전 편극 제거 채널을 고려해 봐요.
모든 밀도 행렬 입력에 대해 완전 혼합 상태를 출력하는 채널이에요. 이 채널에는 네 개의 Kraus 행렬이
필요해요. n이 3 이하인 Kraus 표현을 만드는 건 불가능해요. 작동하는 한 가지 선택이 여기 있고,
또 다른 선택도 있어요. 연습 문제는 이 선택들이 작동하는지 확인하고 필요한 조건이
충족되는지 확인하는 거예요. 두 번째 대안은 기본적으로 qubit을 완전히 편극 제거하거나, 다시 말해
항등을 포함한 네 개의 Pauli 행렬 중 하나를 무작위로 선택하고
해당 unitary 연산을 qubit에 적용해서 완전히 랜덤화하는 것이 가능하다는 걸 보여줘요. 그래서 완전 편극 제거 채널은 혼합
unitary 채널의 또 다른 예시예요. 다룰 세 가지 채널 표현 중 마지막은 Choi 표현이에요. Man-Duen Choi는
행렬 이론과 다른 주제들을 연구하는 수학자이고, Choi 표현은 그의 이름을 딴 거예요.
어떤 의미에서 이 모든 것을 하나로 묶는 1975년에 발표한 정말 우아한 논문에 기반해서요. 채널 Φ의 Choi
표현은 관례적으로 J_Φ로 표시되는 단일 행렬이에요. 구체적으로 입력 시스템에 n개의 고전적 상태가 있고
출력 시스템에 m개의 고전적 상태가 있으면, Φ의 Choi 표현은
n*m × n*m 정방 행렬이 돼요. 정확히 행렬이 어떻게 정의되는지 말씀드리기 전에, 핵심 특성 몇 가지를 언급하고 싶어요.
이건 적어도 표면적으로는 실제 정의 자체가 하지 않는 방식으로 표현에 동기를 부여해요. 첫째로, Stinespring 표현과 Kraus 표현 모두와 달리, Choi 표현은
소위 충실한 표현으로, 모든 채널이 정확히 하나를 갖는다는 의미예요. 이건 꽤 중요해요.
두 채널이 같다는 것은 그것들의 Choi 표현이 같은 경우에만 성립하기 때문이에요. 그래서 두 채널에 대해
두 가지 다른 Stinespring 표현이나 두 가지 다른 Kraus 표현 또는 각각 하나씩 같은 두 가지 다른 설명이 있고
그것들이 실제로 같은 채널인지 알고 싶다면, Choi 표현을 계산해서
같은지 확인하면 돼요. 두 번째 특성은 Choi 표현에 유효한 채널인 경우에만 성립하는
간단한 확인 조건들이 있다는 거예요. 그 특성이 그렇게 특별하진 않아요. 다른 두 표현에 대해서도 같은 말을 할 수 있지만,
그래도 갖는 게 좋은 특성이고, 곧 더 자세히 논의할 거예요. Choi 표현에 대해 주목할 또 한 가지는, 비록 채널을
행렬로 표현하고 있지만, 이 행렬이 직접 채널을 선형 사상으로 나타내지는 않는다는 거예요. 실제로
Choi 표현을 선형 사상을 설명하는 것으로 생각하기보다는 특정 상태를 나타내는 밀도 행렬과 연결하는 게 더 자연스러워요.
하지만 꽤 간단한 공식을 사용해서 Choi 표현으로부터 채널의 작용을 복원하는 건 가능해요.
하지만 그게 단순한 행렬 곱셈만큼 간단하진 않아요.
서론은 이 정도면 충분하고, 실제 정의로 넘어가봐요. Φ가 시스템 X에서 시스템 Y로의 채널이라고 가정하고
입력 시스템 X의 고전적 상태 집합이 Σ라고 가정해요. 출력 시스템의 고전적 상태 집합은 언급할 필요가 없어서
정의에서 이름을 붙일 필요가 없어요. Φ의 Choi 표현은 화면에 표시된 식으로 정의돼요.
입력 시스템의 모든 고전적 상태 A와 B에 걸친 합이 있고,
|a⟩⟨b|와 채널 Φ를 |a⟩⟨b|에 적용한 것의 텐서곱을 합산해요.
이 표현은 공식에 의해 정의되고, 이 공식을 생각하는 몇 가지 다른 방법이 있어요. 하지만 논의하기 전에,
Choi 표현이 때로 두 텐서 인수의 순서가 반대인 약간 다른 방식으로 정의된다는 걸 말씀드릴게요.
즉 Φ(|a⟩⟨b|)가 두 번째 텐서 인수가 아닌 첫 번째 텐서 인수로 나타나요. 하지만 이 두 방식은
이 간단한 대칭성까지는 동등해요. 즉, 이 표현을 사용할 때는
어떤 순서를 사용하는지 명확히 하는 게 좋아요. 이 순서는 Qiskit에서 쓰는 방식이고, 블록 행렬 관점에서
표현을 시각적으로 설명하기도 더 좋아요. 그래서 이걸 사용할 거예요. 블록 행렬
설명을 더 정확히 하면, 고전적 상태 집합 Σ가 어떤 양의 정수 n에 대해 0부터 n-1까지의 정수로 구성된다고 가정하면
J_Φ를 화면에서 보이는 것처럼 블록 행렬로 대안적으로 쓸 수 있어요.
다시 말해, Φ의 Choi 표현은 정확히 하나의 항목이 1이고 나머지 항목이 모두 0인 각 입력 행렬에
Φ를 적용해서 얻는 행렬이에요. 그리고 그것들을 꽤 자연스러운 방식으로
배열해요. 왜 이런 행렬을 형성하고 싶은지 선험적으로 명확하지 않을 수 있지만,
매우 유용한 것으로 밝혀져요. 주목할 한 가지는, A와 B 모두 0부터 n-1까지의 정수를 범위로 할 때
|a⟩⟨b| 행렬들을 포함하는 집합이 모든 n×n 행렬의 공간에 대한 기저를 형성한다는 거예요. 그래서
이 행렬이 있으면, 선형성에 의해 Φ가 임의의 n×n 행렬에 무엇을 하는지 분명히 결정할 수 있어요.
구체적으로는 블록들의 적절한 선형 결합을 취해서요. 그래서 행렬 J_Φ는 실제로 Φ를 선형 사상으로 유일하게
결정해요. 채널의 Choi 표현을 생각하는 또 다른 방법은, 이게
정규화했을 때, 즉 소문자 n으로 표시할 입력 시스템의 고전적 상태 수로 나눴을 때
상태를 밀도 행렬로 표현한다는 거예요. 이렇게 하면 항상 밀도 행렬을 얻는데,
이를 채널의 Choi 상태라고 해요. 더 자세히 살펴보면,
먼저 입력 시스템의 두 개의 동일한 복사본이 있고, 화면에 표시된 양자 상태 벡터 ψ를 고려한다고 상상해 봐요.
이건 이 동일한 시스템 쌍의 소위 최대 얽힘 상태를 나타내요.
예를 들어 Σ가 이진 알파벳이면, 이건 Φ+ 상태예요. 하지만 임의의 Σ 선택에 대해 유사하게 정의된 상태를 생각할 수 있고,
그 결과는 고도로 얽힌 상태인데, 실제로 이 시스템 선택으로 얻을 수 있는 만큼 얽혀 있어요.
상태의 밀도 행렬 표현을 얻기 위해 상태 벡터와 켤레 전치를 곱하고, 이런 모습이에요.
마지막으로 n으로 나눈 채널의 Choi 표현을 생각해 보면, 채널 Φ를 두 번째 시스템에 적용하면 얻을 상태임을 알 수 있어요.
그림 형태로 보면, 이게 어떻게 보이는지예요. 최대 얽힘 상태 ψ에 있는 두 개의 시스템 X 복사본이 있어요. 채널 Φ는
다이어그램에서 위쪽인 두 번째 시스템에 적용되고, 결과 상태가 Φ의 Choi 상태예요. 물론 일반적으로는
두 개의 다른 시스템에 같은 이름을 붙이지 않아요. 일반적으로 두 개의 다른 것에 같은 이름을 붙이는 건 도움이 되지 않지만,
여기서는 말이 돼요.
어쨌든 이건 꽤 자연스러운 구성이에요.
이 경우에는 Choi 표현과의 연결을 만들기 위해서요. 이 방식으로 Choi 표현을 보는 것에서 즉시 도출할 수 있는 몇 가지 함의가 있어요.
하나는 Φ가 유효한 채널이라고 가정하면 Choi 상태가 밀도 행렬이기 때문에, Φ의 Choi 표현이 반드시 양의 반정치여야 한다는 결론을 내릴 수 있어요.
기억하세요, 채널은 항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환해야 한다는 요건이 있고,
이건 그 특수한 경우예요. 두 번째 함의는 임의의 채널 Φ에 대한 Choi 상태를 취하고
출력 시스템 Y를 버리면, 반드시 입력 시스템 X의 완전 혼합 상태가 남는다는 거예요.
그 이유는 시스템에 채널을 적용하고 결과 시스템을 버리는 건 원래 시스템을 그냥 버리는 것과 동등하기 때문이에요.
그리고 최대 얽힘 상태로 그렇게 하면, 남는 밀도 행렬은
n으로 나눈 항등 행렬, 즉 시스템 X에 대한 완전 혼합 상태가 될 거예요. 더 수학적인 용어로는,
임의의 채널과 출력 시스템의 대각합을 합성하면 입력 시스템의 대각합과 같아야 한다는 거예요.
채널은 항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환하는 선형 사상이라는 사실로 인해 대각합을 보존해야 하기 때문이에요.
이 방정식이 있으면 분모 n을 양쪽에서 제거해서
약간 더 깔끔한 조건을 얻을 수 있어요. 말로 하면, 채널의 Choi 표현에서 출력 시스템의 부분 대각합을 수행하면
반드시 입력 시스템의 항등 행렬을 얻어야 해요. 요약하면, 채널의 Choi
표현은 항상 양의 반정치이고, 출력 시스템을 trace out하면 반드시 입력 시스템의 항등 행렬이 남아요.
밝혀진 바에 따르면, 이것들은 필요 조건일 뿐만 아니라 충분 조건이기도 해요. 즉, Φ가 임의의 선형 사상이고 이 두 조건이 모두
성립한다면, Φ는 반드시 유효한 채널이에요. 강의 끝에서 왜 그런지 알게 될 거예요.
몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼게요. 완전 위상 제거 채널부터 시작해서 Choi 표현을 계산하는 건 그냥 공식을 계산하는 문제예요.
완전 위상 제거 채널은 a=b일 때 |a⟩⟨b|를 그대로 두고, 그렇지 않으면 출력이
0이에요. 그래서 합에서 살아남는 항들은 a=b인 것들이고, 결과는 화면에서 직접 표기법으로 표현돼요.
블록 행렬로도 볼 수 있어요. Delta는 대각 항목들을 그대로 두고 비대각 항목들을 0으로 만들어요.
그래서 왼쪽 위와 오른쪽 아래 모서리에 1이 있고 나머지 항목들은 모두 0인 행렬이 남아요.
이건 첫 번째 식과 일치해요. 또 다른 예시로 완전 편극 제거 채널을 고려해 봐요. 공식을 적는 것부터 시작하고,
이전 예시처럼 a가 b와 같지 않을 때는 합에 기여가 없어요.
이번에는 a=b일 때 완전 혼합 상태를 얻고, 이걸 단순화해서
1/2 * (2x2 항등 행렬의 텐서곱)을 얻는데, 이는 1/2 * 4x4
항등 행렬이에요. 블록 행렬 관점에서도 생각해볼 수 있고, 당연히 같은 결과를 얻어요.
마지막 예시로, 단일 qubit에 대한 항등 채널을 고려해 봐요. 쉬운 거예요. 공식이 여기 있고,
물론 항등 채널은 아무것도 안 해요. 결과를 Φ+ 상태와 연관된 밀도 행렬의 두 배로 생각할 수 있고,
이건 이 채널의 Choi 상태를 생각해서 기대하는 것과 일치해요. 블록 행렬로는 이렇게 돼요. 특히 항등 채널의 Choi
표현이 항등 행렬이 아니라는 점에 주목하세요. 이 행렬이에요. 이제 채널을 수학적으로 표현하는 세 가지 다른
방법을 살펴봤어요. 즉 Stinespring 표현, Kraus 표현, 그리고 Choi
표현이에요. 그리고 채널의 정의도 가지고 있는데, 채널은 복합 시스템의 일부에만 적용될 때도
항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환하는 선형 사상이에요. 이 시점에서 자연스럽고 매우 중요한 질문은,
이것들이 모두 동등하다는 걸 어떻게 알 수 있냐는 거예요. 예를 들어, 이 표현들 중 하나로 설명되는 모든 사상이
실제로 유효한 채널임을 어떻게 알 수 있고, 어떤 채널을 빠뜨리지 않았다는 걸 어떻게 알 수 있을까요?
강의의 나머지 부분에서는 이 모든 것을 수학적으로 어떻게 추론할 수 있는지 설명해요.
이것들의 동등성을 받아들이려 하고 어떻게 추론할 수 있는지에 관심이 없다면, 나머지 영상을 건너뛰어도 돼요.
하지만 저는 개인적으로 이 논증이 꽤 세련됐다고 생각하고, 양자 정보 이론에서 때때로 나오는 특정 스타일의 수학적 증명의 좋은 예라고 생각해요.
모든 세부 사항을 다루지는 않을 거예요. 일부는 여러분에게 남겨두거나, 모든 것이 자세히 적혀 있는 이번 강의의 문서에서 찾을 수 있어요.
하지만 어떻게 작동하는지 합리적으로 명확한 그림을 보여드리고 싶어요. 하려는 건 일련의 명제들의 동등성을 증명하는 거예요.
이를 위한 방법은 함의의 사이클을 설정하는 거예요. 특히 채널의 정의부터 시작할 거예요.
항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환하는 선형 사상이라는 의미에서요.
이 정의로부터 이 채널의 Choi 표현이 이미 논의한 두 조건을 만족해야 한다는 추론을 할 수 있고,
실제로 이미 이걸 했어요. 채널의 Choi 상태의 맥락에서 논의했어요. 그런 다음
정의에 대한 것은 모두 잊고 Choi 표현에서 작업해요. 그리고 Choi 표현에 대한 두 조건이 주어지면, 사상 Φ의 Kraus 표현이 반드시 존재한다는 결론을 내려요.
그런 다음 유사한 걸 해요. Choi 표현에 대한 건 잊고
임의의 Kraus 표현에서 작업하면, 사상 Φ에 대한 Stinespring 표현이 반드시 있다는 추론을 할 수 있어요. 그리고 이런 논증들은
어떤 의미에서 기계적이어서, 원한다면 특정 채널에 대해 화살표에 따라 변환을 실제로 수행할 수 있어요.
그렇게 하려면요. 마지막 함의는 사상 Φ에 대한 Stinespring 표현이 있으면
그 사상이 실제로 유효한 채널이어야 한다는 추론이에요. 그리고 다시 한번, 이미 그걸 했어요. 이번에는 Stinespring 표현의 맥락에서요.
이 네 가지 함의를 모두 합치면, 이 네 가지가 모두 동등하다는 걸 알 수 있어요. 어떤 것에서 시작해도
함의를 추이적으로 따라가서 나머지 것들 중 어느 것에도 도달할 수 있기 때문이에요. 첫 번째 함의부터 시작할 거예요.
채널 Φ, 즉 항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환하는 선형 사상이 있으면, Choi
표현이 앞서 확인한 두 조건을 만족한다는 거예요. 즉 양의 반정치이고
출력 시스템을 trace out하면 입력 시스템의 항등 행렬을 얻는다는 거예요. 방금 전에 언급했듯이,
이미 Choi 상태의 맥락에서 이 함의를 다뤘어요. 특히 채널의 Choi 표현을 n, 즉 입력 시스템의
고전적 상태 수로 나누면 밀도 행렬을 얻고, 게다가 입력 시스템의 축소된 상태는
그 상태에서 시스템 X는 완전 혼합 상태, 즉 n으로 나눈 항등 행렬이에요. 분모를 제거하면 두 조건을 얻어요.
두 조건이에요. 그래서 이 함의는 이미 다뤘기 때문에 꽤 빠르고 쉬워요.
이제 두 번째 함의를 살펴봐요. 이번에는 두 요건을 만족한다고 가정하는 사상의 Choi 표현에서 시작하고,
목표는 이 사상에 대한 Kraus 표현을 찾는 거예요. 앞서 이야기한 요건을 만족하는 거죠.
이 함의는 어떤 의미에서 꽤 기계적이에요. 약간의 선형 대수가 필요하고,
주로 행렬과 벡터를 꽤 영리한 방식으로 조작하는 걸로 귀결돼요.
Choi 표현이 양의 반정치라는 가정에서 시작하는데, 이게 우리가 가정하고 있는 두 요건 중 첫 번째예요.
양의 반정치 행렬의 개념은 양자 정보에서 근본적으로 중요해요. 밀도 행렬의 맥락에서만이 아니에요.
이게 없으면 이걸 작동시킬 수 없을 정도로 절대적으로 중요해요. 특히 J_Φ가
양의 반정치라는 가정은 화면에 표시된 형태로 표현할 수 있게 해줘요. 어떤
벡터 s_0부터 s_의 선택과 어떤 양의 정수 n의 선택으로요. 이것들이 반드시
단위 벡터일 필요는 없다는 걸 명시적으로 언급할게요. 이런 형태의 표현을 얻는 한 가지 방법은 양의 반정치 행렬에 대한 스펙트럼 정리에서 오는데,
이전 강의에서 논의했어요. 여기서는 스펙트럼 분해에서처럼 고유값이 명시적으로 나타나지 않지만,
양의 반정치 행렬의 고유값은 항상 비음수 실수라는 걸 기억하세요. 또한 이 벡터 s_0부터 s_이
단위 벡터일 필요가 없다는 것도 기억하세요. 그래서 할 수 있는 건 고유값의 제곱근을 취하고
스펙트럼 분해에서 얻는 단위 고유벡터에 곱해서 이
벡터 s_0부터 s_을 얻는 거예요. 실제로 이 증명에서 이 벡터들이 직교할 필요는 없어요.
스펙트럼 분해에서는 그게 나오지만, 여기서는 사용하지 않을 거예요. 스펙트럼 정리에서 오지 않은 J_Φ의 다른 표현이 있더라도
괜찮아요. 이제 화면에 표시된 것처럼 이 벡터들 각각을 분해하는데,
이건 이 벡터들이 시스템 쌍 XY의 양자 상태 벡터이고 X 시스템에 대해 표준 기저 측정을 수행하는 것처럼 하는 거예요.
명확히 말씀드리면, 여기서 아무것도 측정하지 않아요. 항상 가능한 이 형태로 벡터를 쓰는 것뿐이에요.
이제 트릭이 나와요. Kraus 행렬 a_0부터 a_을 정의하는데, 벡터 s_0부터 s_의 앞에서 K
A를 뽑아내고 뒤집어서 bra A가 되게 한 다음 화면의 방정식에 표시된 것처럼 오른쪽에 붙여요.
이걸 생각하는 한 가지 방법은 기본적으로 이 벡터들을 접어서 행렬로 만드는 거예요. A_K의 열들을 서로 위에 쌓으면
s_k를 다시 얻게 돼요. 이 행렬들은 대응하는 벡터와 정확히 같은 항목들을 가지고 있지만,
행렬을 얻도록 항목들을 다르게 재배열했을 뿐이에요. 또한 이 행렬들을 직접 표기법으로 순수하게 기호적으로 생각할 수도 있어요.
여기에 쓰여진 것처럼요. 이제 이 시점에서 명백한 질문이 있어요. 왜 이게 작동할까요? 왜 작동하는지에 너무 오래 머무르지 말고
그냥 작동하는지 확인해 봐요. 이를 위해 이 행렬들로 정의되는 새로운 사상을 정의해요.
Kraus 행렬로 처리해서요. 이제 할 수 있는 건 이
새로운 사상의 Choi 표현을 계산하는 거예요. 그러면 시작했던 사상 Φ의 Choi 표현과 같다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
그리고 Choi 표현이 충실하기 때문에, 이는 두 사상이 실제로 같다는 의미예요.
이 영상에서 대수를 다루지 않을 거예요. 직접 확인할 수 있는데, 꽤 기계적이고 좋은 연습이 돼요.
필요한 모든 것이 화면에 있어요.
두 번째 조건에 대해서는 아직 아무 말도 하지 않았지만,
두 조건이 동등하다는 것은 화면 하단에 표시된 방정식을 확인해서 알 수 있어요.
여기서 T는 행렬 전치를 가리키는데, 이는 |a⟩⟨b|를 |b⟩⟨a|로 바꾸는 선형 사상으로 생각할 수 있어요.
공식이 작동하게 만드는 데 필요한 거예요. 요약하면,
이 함의에는 분명히 약간의 대수가 필요하지만, 앞서 말했듯이 모두 꽤 기계적이에요.
기본적으로 인덱스 체조라고 어떤 이들이 부르는 거예요. 하지만 직접 해보고 머릿속에서 소화할 기회를 준다면,
Choi 표현과 Kraus 표현이 어떻게 관련되는지 더 잘 이해하게 될 거예요. 세 번째 함의는
사상 Φ의 Kraus 표현에서, 일반적인 조건이 있는 곳에서 Stinespring 표현으로 가는 거예요. 이건 꽤
이전 함의와 정신적으로 비슷해요. 기계적이고 순수하게 대수적인 용어로 볼 수 있고 확인할 수 있다는 의미에서요.
아이디어는 실제로 꽤 간단해요. 할 수 있는 건 Kraus 행렬들을 가져다가 화면에 표시된 것처럼 서로 위에 쌓아서 더 큰 행렬의 일부를 형성하는 거예요.
이것이 채워지면 Stinespring 표현의 unitary 행렬 U가 될 거예요.
unitary 행렬은 정방 행렬이어야 하므로, 그렇게 하기 위해 필요한 만큼의 나머지
열들을 채워야 해요. 하지만 unitary 행렬을 얻는 한 그것들이 무엇인지는 실제로 차이가 없어요.
U가 unitary라는 걱정을 잠시 제쳐두고 U 행렬에서 얻는 Stinespring 표현으로 정의되는 선형 사상에만 집중한다면,
사상이 시작했던 Kraus 표현으로 정의된 원래 사상 Φ와 같다는 걸 알게 돼요.
이건 이 영상에서 다루지 않을 증명의 또 다른 부분이에요. 이번 강의의 문서에서 세부 사항을 찾을 수 있지만,
직접 시간을 내서 해보고 싶을 수도 있어요. 항상 그렇듯이 시리즈에서
다이어그램을 해석할 때 ket 순서 규칙을 사용한다는 걸 기억하세요. 그래서 W와 G는 방정식에서 왼쪽의 텐서 인수에 해당해요.
그리고 직접 해본다면, 방정식에서 왼쪽의 텐서 인수로 |0⟩⟨0|가 있기 때문에
U에서 관련 있는 유일한 부분은 Kraus 행렬들로 주어지는 부분이라는 걸 알게 될 거예요.
U의 열들을 unitary가 되도록 채우기만 하면 되지만, 이는 a_0부터 a_로 형성된 열들이
서로 위에 쌓았을 때 정규직교해야 한다는 것을 요구해요. 여기서 Kraus 표현에 두는 조건이 중요해져요.
실제로 이 조건은 열들이 정규직교하다는 것과 정확히 동등해요. 이 결론을 도출하는 데 필요한 관련 수학적 관계들이
화면 하단에 표시돼 있어요. 잠깐 멈추고 확인해 보거나,
더 자세한 내용은 문서를 참조하세요. 간단히 말하면, 이 함의와 이전 함의에서 일어나고 있는 일은
같은 수학적 연산을 다르지만 동등한 방식으로 설명하고 있다는 거예요.
이 모든 것의 핵심은 본질적으로 행렬 곱셈이에요. 네 번째이자 마지막 함의는 사상에 대한
Stinespring 표현이 있으면 그 사상이 실제로 유효한 채널이어야 한다는 걸 확립해요.
앞서 언급했듯이, Stinespring 표현을 논의할 때 이미 이 함의를 다뤘어요.
요약하면,
초기화된 작업 공간 시스템을 도입하는 것은 유효한 채널이에요. 고정된 밀도 행렬을 주어진 밀도 행렬에 텐서곱하면
항상 밀도 행렬이 나오고, 텐서곱의 쌍선형성에 의해 선형 사상이에요.
unitary 연산은 강의 앞부분에서 논의했듯이 항상 유효한 채널이에요. 시스템을 trace out하는 것도 유효한 채널인데,
부분 대각합이 항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환하는 선형 사상이기 때문이에요. 마지막으로
채널의 합성은 항상 채널이에요. 꽤 단순하지만 그 자체로 확실히 관찰할 가치가 있어요. 이 네 가지 함의로
세 가지 채널 표현과 채널의 원래 정의의 동등성을 확립했어요.
특히 채널의 정의부터 시작해서, 그 정의가 Choi
표현이 반드시 두 가지 기본 조건을 만족한다는 것을 함의하는 걸 봤어요. 그런 다음 그 조건들이 Kraus 표현을 찾을 수 있게 해주고, 이는 다시
Stinespring 표현을 찾을 수 있게 해준다는 걸 봤어요. 마지막으로 Stinespring 표현의 존재가 실제로
유효한 채널을 갖는다는 걸 드러낸다는 것도 봤어요. 물론 기술적인 세부 사항들이 있고, 처음 볼 때는
반드시 간단하지 않아요. 하지만 흥미롭고 주목할 만한 건, 이 함의들이 실제로 가능한 한 쉽게 만들도록 설정되어 있다는 거예요.
수학에서는 쉬운 길을 택하는 것에 절대 수치심을 느낄 필요가 없어요.
예를 들어, 모든 채널이 Stinespring 표현이나 Kraus 표현을 갖는다는 건 전혀 명백하지 않아요.
하지만 모든 채널의 Choi 표현이 우리가 연결한 두 조건을 만족한다는 걸 결론 내리기는 상대적으로 쉽고,
그게 다른 두 표현으로 가는 더 대수적인 경로를 따르게 해줘요. 비슷한 맥락에서
Stinespring 표현에서 정의로 돌아가는 마지막 함의도 상대적으로 간단해요.
그리고 요건이 충족된다고 가정하면, Choi 표현에서 채널만 얻고 다른 사상은 없다는 결론을 내릴 수 있어요.
앞서 암시했듯이, 이 함의들을 논증하는 방식이 충분히 기계적이어서 표현들 사이를
쉽게 변환할 수 있어요. 강의 앞부분에서 다룬 예시들로 돌아가면, 실제로
표현들 사이를 변환하는 게 때로 꽤 쉽고 직접적으로 가능하다는 걸 알 수 있을 거예요. 이것으로
채널에 관한 모든 내용을 다룬 강의가 끝났어요. 채널이 무엇인지 이야기하고 기본 예시들을 살펴봤어요. 채널을 표현하는 세 가지 방법을 논의하고
이 표현들의 동등성을 확립하는 기술적인 세부 사항에 대해 깊이 파고들었어요.
양자 정보의 일반 공식화에서 측정에 관한 다음 강의에도 함께해 주세요. 그때까지 안녕히 계세요!